el abastecimiento de agua no mejora en
Uruguay el país suramericano enfrenta su
peor sequía en más de siete décadas y
sus efectos ya sienten Incluso en la
capital Montevideo allí comprar agua
embotellada se ha convertido en una
Odisea ahora el tema del agua o sea que
estamos en una situación que que la
verdad y no se puede comprar el agua Ese
es el sentir que hay gente que sí puede
y hay gente que no puede o sea persona
que somos de barcos recursos no podemos
los residentes de Montevideo aseguran
que la calidad del agua de Grifo ha
empeorado por su parte las autoridades
antes mentido que el agua no sea
consumible también han recomendado que
se limite el uso a personas embarazadas
o con problemas renales es difícil está
difícil por el tema del gusto
el malestar que te causa en el estómago
también te da dolor de cabeza el agua la
canilla la ausencia de agua es notable
en pasos Severino La Represa de Uruguay
que abastece acerca del 60% de la
población actualmente está
experimentando los niveles más bajos
jamás registrados y según las
autoridades su agua podría agotarse por
completo en julio si no llueve o nunca
este de que se hizo La Represa nunca
había visto en estas condiciones verdad
el caudal del agua muy poquito este el
presidente del país Luis lacalle Pou
también alertó que si no hay
precipitaciones en los próximos días
habrá un periodo en el que el agua del
país No será bebible además prometió que
entregará recursos para que más de medio
millón de uruguayos de la zona
metropolitana puedan acceder a dos
litros de agua embotellada diaria